I'm Sandra Smith I'm Bret Baier I means
lay your heart and this is the Fox News
rundown
Friday April 24th 2020
I'm Jessica Rosenthal as several states
begin opening up some parts of their
economies some wonder if it's too soon
others point out over the past five
weeks 26 million people have become
unemployed we have to think in terms of
trade off the opening needs to happen
eventually it needs to happen slowly
need to happen in a smart way I'm Dave
Anthony he's the only black Republican
ever elected to the house then the
Senate and he's a big Trump supporter so
Tim Scott is sometimes shunned have had
the pain of rejection from the
african-american community and the
easiest way to deal with that is to
recognize that the journey that I'm on
is less about me and I'm Tom Shalu
I've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
conservative economist Thomas ol once
said there are no solutions only
trade-offs and that may best describe
the situation for many right now in
dealing with the Cova 19 virus Americans
are watching closely as governors like
Georgia's Brian Kemp begin reopening
things with restrictions in the same way
that we carefully closed businesses and
urged operations to end to mitigate the
virus spread today we are announcing
plans to incrementally and safely
reopen sectors of our economy in
Tennessee it means most state parks are
reopening today in Texas retailers can
start offering curbside pickup in
Wisconsin golf courses are reopening
with some restrictions Oklahoma's
allowing barber shops and salons to open
with restrictions and Georgia is
allowing those kinds of shops to open as
well along with tattoo parlors and gyms
Vice President Mike Pence said they're
encouraging elective surgeries to resume
if they can and Pence says 16 states
have now announced formal reopening
plans and we're encouraged to see so
many states embracing the phased
approach to reopening their economies
that's contemplated in our guidelines
for opening up America again for
instance Governor Mike parson and
Missouri announced the show-me strong
recovery plan has two initial phases
intended to protect the most at-risk one
Democratic strategist tweeted that in
Georgia's case the governor was allowing
human sacrifices to begin today but even
some scientists are talking about a need
for balance a little soon to let off the
social distancing but at the same time
what everyone is going to have to
understand is that things are going to
have to reopen sooner or later
Andrew numers an associate professor of
public health and an epidemiologist at
the University of california-irvine you
know from a purely epidemiological
standpoint we could keep the country
closed for 15 months or more and that
would benefit in terms of reducing
mortality and reducing infections but
it's just not going to happen in the
real world it just will not happen and
so we have to think in terms of
trade-offs and if it's a reopening needs
happen eventually it needs to happen
slowly it needs to happen in a smart way
we don't just throw the doors wide open
as quickly as they were shut slam shut
is a place like Georgia going too far in
your mind right now reopening gyms
salons tattoo parlors or if you're gonna
start just rip the band-aid off kind of
in a place maybe like Georgia well one I
don't think you should rip the band-aid
off that's the whole point
I mean ripping the band-aid off is not
what's called for I mean we want to do
this slowly I would say Jim's reopening
you know again assuming it's we're
talking about four four customers to go
you know work out you know that would be
one of the last placements that should
be open right not not one of the first
so rescue because I read something
interesting I read you know these
shutdowns were never going to stop or
kill the virus entirely writing you've
referenced that they were to buy us time
so our healthcare system didn't get
overrun and that has happened to a
certain extent depending on who you ask
right we've ramped up PPEs bed space
ventilators and we are more prepared
again depending on who you ask
so is it time to start letting people
some people you know go out and about
and work while maybe telling older or
vulnerable people hey you don't need to
be a part of this early reopening would
that sort of be I guess a you know that
a mixed bag way to go is to initially
start this definitely I mean well I mean
one thing to keep in mind is that you
know people are going to open and start
opening up black market businesses you
know it if they're prevented from
reopening their regular businesses
forever so you know nobody wants that so
testing need still needs to come up it's
in in certain places I mean there are
lots of differences from place to place
in how available testing is yeah but I
mean some businesses are gonna have to
bit by bit reopen and as you make a
perfect example of older people who may
be more vulnerable or someone who
doesn't have anything with which to
cover their mouth and nose you know I
mean may not wish to go out people are
gonna have to start judging their own
risk and the risk that their household
faces
because as the government starts lifting
and hopefully slowly and bit by bit but
as they start lifting these lockdowns
people are going to have to be their own
first line of defense for their own
selves and for their own health hope how
key though is testing right because you
look at a country like South Korea they
flattened their curve quickly they were
testing doing mass testing really early
on and then you hear you know you and I
are both in California you hear our
governor Newsom say before he opens
anything or allows anything to be
reopened he wants a sixty thousand
people a day at minimum tested and what
in your mind when you look at like a
South Korea and you hear the Governor of
California
how important is mass testing at this
point massive massive thing is actually
really important and it's kind of
complicated because I think some people
kind of set-asides testing they're like
our testing testing testing testing you
know and all they want to talk about is
testing and it's important to remember
that testing doesn't treat or cure and
any any disease but testing gives you
information so testing actually can
prevent further cases because if you
found out oh my gosh this dry cough I
have is actually coded I'm gonna you
know stay home from work for the next
two weeks or versus you know versus
having no information and just thinking
love this is just a dry cough and I'm
gonna go to work so testing is important
testing gives us information testing is
not everything and we should stop crying
over spilt milk about the fact that we
didn't have testing early on the way
South Korea did I mean it would have
been better and there certainly is going
to have to be a calling to account and
an investigation into why we were so
slow to get testing to where it needed
to be and we need more transparency and
all of this but from the public health
standpoint going forward you know we're
not going to nip this thing in the bud
the way the South Koreans did with
testing early because we're no longer
early but but talk to me more about
South Korea for a second because I want
your thoughts on why they were able to
flatten their curves too early aside
from having mass testing I'm reading all
kinds of things like for example their
how they had deal with MERS in 2015 yes
South Korea has
lots of experience with coronavirus they
actually got kind of caught unawares by
MERS a little bit they had a returning
traveler from Middle East who had the
disease and there's actually some
Hospital Hospital transmission that is
to say inside the hospital there and so
they they got a lot of experience with
that they learned from their mistakes
mistakes were made with MERS in the
early days in 2014 in South Korea but
they learned very well from those
mistakes about isolation the importance
of you know making sure a patient who
has a new respiratory pathogen is
treated in a room all by him or herself
so you know the South Koreans have
experiencing with these corona viruses
they have they had stockpiles of PPE
they had testing they really were poised
to handle it well on the flip side of a
South Korea you've got a country like
Sweden you know they didn't really lock
down much of anything right and and they
have just as we are talking right now
over about 16,000 cases in over 2,000
deaths that is far more than their
neighbors by the way of Norway Denmark
and Finland but of course it's far fewer
than you know other places maybe if we
compared to Italy or New York what's
what do you make of a decision like
Sweden's yes has been kind of defiant
they didn't lock down at all practically
they did encourage social distancing but
they kept things open and I mean it's a
perfect example of the trade-offs that
we're gonna that get made and the
trade-offs that will have to be made as
we begin to reopen the American economy
Sweden has more deaths than any of their
Scandinavian neighbors and a higher
death rate so even adjusting for
population size so I mean Sweden is not
a unqualified success story I mean the
Swedes have enjoyed more freedoms and no
lock down but they've also paid the
price in in death so you cannot
unambiguously say well Sweden did did
the right thing and look you know the
Swedes have been so free all this time I
mean more Suites have died than than
their neighbours so it's it's not a slam
dunk
did South Korea do the trade-off
situation maybe the best of any country
and
they they did shut down schools but they
did not shut down businesses even when
all of this was happening they did
intense temperature checks of people
right walking into buildings they they
had apps I mean right people were
signing up for apps to let them know
when they came into contact with
somebody who may have been infected I
don't know if Americans would go for
that but when you look at a country that
maybe did the the balancing act of the
trade-offs early on is it South Korea I
think South Korea gets gets the A+ yeah
South Korea probably has the best
response I mean I mean mainland China
you know it has a very authoritarian
government and so they can do things in
terms of absolute lockdown and
delivering food you know to each
household and whatnot that Wuhan did but
you know that's not going to work almost
anywhere else apart apart from mainland
China so I think South Korea in terms of
yet in terms of outside China gets gets
the best grade I mean South Korea
handled it extremely well but I mean you
know they did have a weak first quarter
economically as a result of the changes
so they're not immune from the economic
effects and and also they're they're not
out of the woods in terms of we've seen
some uptick in cases in Singapore and
and and Japan some of some other Asian
countries that did quite well in the
first round and and are now seeing
second waves or you can call it a
prolonged first wave you can call
whatever you like but the point is until
we have a vaccine no country is truly
out of the woods and finally when we
talk about trade-offs right and
balancing acts here what about travel
what should how should the you know the
federal government handle travel to and
from other countries allowing travel in
from other countries that maybe didn't
take the kind of steps we did if we
really don't want a second wave there's
so much coronavirus in the United States
right now that wearing too much about
travel restrictions is not the best use
of our energy I mean you know people can
go to a beach today in Florida and and
mingle with hundreds of other people if
they said cheese because some
at least in some areas the beaches are
reopened so if we're so worried about
preventing every infection you know we
could we could prevent loss of them just
just by closing the beaches again but
that's a decision that people have made
in Florida but the beaches are going to
stay open so I don't think a few people
coming in on a flight is really our
number one concern professor Andrew
numerous thank you so much for your time
my pleasure thank you for having me on
your show this is Tom shaloo with your
Fox News commentary
coming up when the house came back
Thursday to vote on that nearly 500
billion dollar package for hospitals
coronavirus testing and to replenish the
empty fund for small business loans
lawmakers did it in person there was no
proxy voting like House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi had considered she instead wants
that issue studied to give members as
many options as possible and to do so in
a way that again is respectful of this
being the coronavirus and not just for
how we do business generally but in this
specific time as a also a template for
any other kind of emergency that might
arise but Republicans are wary other
people are able to get their jobs done
with appropriate changes and appropriate
precautions Congressman Tom Cole I do
think we are capable of working the
House of Representatives and I will be
extraordinarily cautious about giving up
procedures and precedents that are 230
plus years old remote voting is also
something being considered in the Senate
I think under emergency situations we
should be able to vote remotely senator
Tim Scott is there a Republican from
South Carolina if the business of the
country needs to be done I think we
should be able to do it from a place
outside of the capital from an emerges
and point in other words in the midst of
a pandemic where you can't travel you
should be able to vote and if you can
travel you should come back to
Washington and vote in in the capital
but there are circle
chances that we would never have thought
of before the pandemic we're having the
ability to remote vote based on the
circumstances on the ground it's so
important and I support that concept not
I'm not sure that everybody does we're
not doing it but it is in fact a
positive more than it is a negative
there are some who think though there
are constitutional issues with the idea
of not being there in person to vote can
you imagine us not funding our
Department of Defense because we can't
get back to Washington because of a
crisis that stops us from being able to
travel there I can't imagine us not
being able to fund the 11 billion
dollars in the cares act or even approve
it because we're not able to come back
to Washington eleven billion dollars for
vaccines and treatments forty five
billion for FEMA those resources
required votes and if we can't have
agreement we should have a mechanism to
take care of that but I would welcome
the conversation around the
constitutionality of voting remotely and
frankly I look forward to understanding
a different position than the one that I
hold senator Tim Scott is now an author
with a book that came out this month
opportunity knocks how hard work
community and business can improve lives
and end poverty a story that takes him
from starting out poor in South Carolina
to ending up in Washington being a
freshman in high school
flunking world geography and civics
civics is the study of politics my good
tells me God has a sense of humor I
became a United States Senator I will
say failing in Spanish in English as a
freshman as well my joke is when you
fail two languages no one considers you
bilingual but they will call you by
Ignat because you can't speak in any
language yeah just going through those
lessons and hardships reminds me that
this truly is the most amazing country
on earth where a guy whose rates in a
single-parent household mired in poverty
not do
well in school everything seems to be
going against you and then through the
prayers of a mother the help of a mentor
all of that turns around in those messes
that I created become a part of my
message that's a blessing and that is
only possible in a nation as good as
ours wanna fast forward you've continued
you grew when you built businesses and
you got into politics you were
successful in the state level you ran
for Congress and won then you get a call
from Governor nikki Haley and she offers
you the chance to be a United States
Senator which you've taken and obviously
this historic you are the only African
American to be a Republican in the house
and then in the Senate were you aware of
that when you took the job I was
definitely not and nikki Haley the
governor at the time afforded me an
opportunity that it was a shocking wow
she says would you like to be a senator
I said to myself let me pray about it of
course I didn't say that I said yes we
were off and running in the next morning
11 a.m. we did a press conference and
more cameras than I've ever seen in one
place
with my delegation standing with me
which was a blessing
you started your book about how you were
on your way to the White House and you
were about to have a meeting with
President Trump and you were nervous
because you were critical of the
president and how he had handled the
Charlottesville mess and the clash
between white supremacists and people in
Charlottesville take us to that and why
did you start your book there in the
aftermath the Charlottesville
controversy I was fairly critical of the
president's approach to people being on
both sides I found this calmness to be
somewhat insensitive and interestingly
enough the White House calls me on
Friday evening it says the president
would like to sit down and talk with you
about your public comments and as you
can imagine having the president against
you as a Republican in South Carolina
that is that Saints ruby-red is not a
good idea so
so when you spoke out you when you spoke
out you had people in your state who
weren't happy with you right no question
they were unhappy with me when I started
speaking out not everyone but a very
loud vocal chorus but I thought it was
the right thing to do and the president
was what he has been with me the entire
relationship that we shared is he was
very kind yeah we spoke for over an hour
I didn't change his mind he didn't
change my mind but he says at the end of
our time together he says the most
remarkable thing he says help me help
those I may have a signal for the
President of the United States the
leader of the free world the show
deference to just the senator to him for
him to extend an olive branch
unnecessarily doing so told me so much
about his character that I am today a
fan probably one of his largest loudest
supporters because I know the heart of
the man too many people don't understand
the President of the United States
particularly people coming from
communities of color and the president
is the he's the quintessential
counter-puncher if you hit him he is
going to hit you back his critics have
called him a racist so many times notic
not just a racist his critics have
called him a white supremacist yeah dead
wrong and offensive and to further
illustrate that Senator Scott says his
mother will never forget what happened
on her 75th birthday I sent a note to
the chief of staff saying I would love
for the president just to jot a little
note and send her a little note if he
can't write didn't know whether he would
do it or not but the President Trump on
her birthday calls us on the way to her
party to spend ten minutes talking to a
wonderful single mom who was stunned
into silence
this is Donald Trump right this is
Donald Trump you're talking about yes
it's remark
so many people that do not believe that
exists it happens every time this des
it's funny thing I have been in the room
with I don't know 50 African American
leaders and the president everybody's
laughing they're talking about things
they're not always on the same page by
the way but the camaraderie and the
instant bond that you feel with them
it's palpable and for those naysayers
who take great pleasure and denigrating
the president's character listen when
he's wrong call him out but when he's
right
give him the same same blessing of your
support as you don't give him when you
disagree with him he's helping
disproportionately communities of color
when he puts as the top priority keeping
community safe and then making sure that
people are sentenced justly he's helping
minority communities when he sat down
and asked that question and allowed to
my allow his support of the opportunity
zones to be public within 24 hours of
that conversation he brought back 67
billion dollars to the poorest
communities not government money private
sector money to combat the issue of
poverty the senator working with the
president
earned him a standing ovation during the
State of the Union address back in
February jobs and investments are
pouring in to 9,000 previously neglected
neighborhoods
thanks to Opportunity Zones a plan
spearheaded by senator Tim Scott as part
of our great Republican tax cuts
so where are these zones and how do they
work so opportunity zones are an
opportunity for people to defer their
capital gains tax that they would
currently owe in order to get that
deferral you have to make a long-term
investment in one of the distressed
communities around the country there are
over 8,700 designated opportunity zones
and by doing so you defer your capital
gains tax but at the same time whatever
you're investing in is the new
investment if you keep it there for ten
years you have no capital gains tax what
this is done it's provided an
opportunity for people and for places to
receive a second look so they have a
first and a new chance for prosperity
you as again an african-american who's a
Republican do you find sometimes you're
dismissed by many others in your
community because you're not Democrats
and how do you deal with that when you
are yes I have had the pain of rejection
from the african-american community and
the easiest way to deal with that is to
recognize that the journey that I'm on
is less about me and more about
providing assistance to people who are
in the same position I found myself as a
young kid growing up in a single-parent
household mired in poverty one final
story in 2008 before he was in Congress
Tim Scott a Republican helped his
grandfather who can't read but was
determined to make history go to the
polls and vote for a Democrat the first
black president Barack Obama after Kazan
we pushed a button together and I will
say without any question it was one of
the most powerful experiences in his
lifetime to know that his country had
changed during his lifetime where he
could vote for an african-american for
president and it says so much as my
grandfather taught me it's easier Timmy
this day should never have happened
because the South Carolina that I grew
up in he said in the 1920s would never
allow this to happen and you're too
of slaves yes exactly absolutely and we
started in Orangeburg County in South
Carolina and because of the
transformation of the heart of the
American people the southern heart in
particular I'm able to represent the
state that at one point my grandfather
couldn't even finish school in senator
Tim Scott from South Carolina again
congratulations on your book thank you
so much for joining us
god bless thank you so much have a good
one
[Music]
from the Fox News podcasts Network
download and listen to the untold story
with Martha McCallum the host of the
story on Fox News Channel sits down with
major newsmakers each week to get their
untold stories subscribe and listen now
by going to Fox News podcasts dot-com
subscribe to this podcast at Fox News
podcasts comm and now some good news
with Tanya J powers an Australian boy
who has been bullied because of his name
has gotten a special gift
Korona DeVries who is eight lives in
Australia when actor Tom Hanks and his
wife actress and singer Rita Wilson
tested positive for kovat 19 while they
were in Australia corona DeVries sent
them a letter then this time mrs. Hank
my name is Khurana I heard on the news
you and your wife had caught the crying
virus are you okay the story of the boys
letter aired on local TV and that's when
he said he'd been getting bullied
because of his name with schoolmates
calling him coronavirus so Tom Hanks
sent him a present
the retro corona typewriter he happened
to have brought to Australia with him
and he wrote back saying quote your
letter made my wife and I feel so
wonderful you're the only person I've
ever known to have the name corona like
the ring around the Sun a crown Hanks
wrote I thought this typewriter would
suit you ask a grown-up how it works and
use it to write me back then he added a
PS saying you've got a friend in me a
reference to Hanks character woody in
Toy Story Corona says he feels like he's
famous and he's learning to use the
typewriter and as for that letter he
owes the actor I'm gonna write back say
looks like Tom Hanks has a friend in him
Tanya Joy powers Fox News
[Music]
it's time for your Fox News commentary
salut what's on your mind I'm recording
today from my yard where's my dad used
to call it the ad it's a nice day get
out to the yard got my audio rig outside
here you know we're all spending a lot
of time at home and one of the strangest
things that's happened during this
coronavirus crisis that were in is that
the approach to almost everything has
become split along the left/right red
state blue state divided and it seems
the latest heated argument is when is
too soon to end the shutdown now most
regular folks I think are itching to get
back to work
I certainly am and I think we're gonna
be able to handle it just fine
now why do I think this it's not based
on my political ideology and it's not
because of something I read in the
newspaper or somebody I watched on cable
news it's because I've been out several
times and I'm assuming you have to most
of us if we're not essential workers are
making quick runs out of our home I've
been to the grocery store twice I've
been to a home-improvement store once a
taco shop twice to a pizza place and
last night I made a beer run on my bike
to a local bar that's selling six-packs
to go in every instance the merchants of
dealt with the health recommendations in
their own way the employees wear masks
and gloves and there's ample hand
sanitizer available they're observing
proper distance the stores have 6 foot
spacing in the lines at the registers
inside the stores or they're only
allowing a certain number of customers
inside the store at a time the smaller
establishments have curbside service
they pay by phone or credit card there's
no contact there's no touching it's all
very tidy these store employees are
behaving like medical personnel in a
hospital responsibly as far as my
workplace goes today I am working from
home but I've been into the Fox News
building several times to tape TV shows
and all the employees observe very
strict procedures I've felt perfectly
safe
at all times when I go out for my daily
run or a bike ride my neighbors that are
on the outside are all behaving
responsibly as well seems that most
people know how to do what they have to
do to be safe the narrative that's
playing out on TV and on social media
seems to be do you want to be risky and
go back to work what do you want to be
safe and stay inside most people I think
are sensible most people realize we can
do both I'm Tom shallow you've been
listening to the Fox News rundown and
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at Fox News podcasts calm and
for up-to-the-minute news go to Fox
news.com
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes